bonjour s'il ya cet automne bonjour à
tous non violent et bonne santé
meilleurs voeux à tous les auditeurs et
auditrices de martinique 1ère merci
d'être dense arcady conseillère
exécutive en charge de l'éducation
vous êtes désormais aussi candidate à la
députation dans la circonscription du
sud on vous pensé beaucoup plus
intéressé par un poste de maire à
rivière-salée plutôt que la députation
alors 2 à peine intéressé par ce job
bien précis vous y allez contre et forcé
car c'est vous qui pourriez donner la
victoire la droite selon les termes de
vos propres amis politiques
alors effectivement c'est à notre avis
une chance au niveau de ces élections de
proposer notre candidature à gabriel à
grands coups et à moi même pour faire en
sorte que notre famille politique puisse
obtenir effectivement un poste de député
vous me confirmer que vous étiez à peine
intéressé par ce port cette fonction
c'est à dire que vous savez moi je suis
un petit peu comme ça quand je prends
une responsabilité je les assume à fond
et je pense avoir montré assez est en
fait le set
cette possibilité d'aller au député
m'est apparue sur le coup comme quelque
chose de c'est pas facile non plus un
d'aller au député c'est une élection
majeure sa demande aussi bien des dés de
l'argent que de la disponibilité que des
des épaules mais avait toujours été une
femme ambitieuse en politique
alors c'est tout même alors ambitieuse
oui mais pas forcément pour moi
ambitieuse pour la côte aussi bien à
cause féminine que la cause des
personnes qui ont envie d'oeuvrer pour
la martinique donc oui je peux porter
cette ambition et je n'ai pas le dire je
n'ai pas honte de le dire et je pense
qu'effectivement dans le sud
nous avons une réelle carte à jouer vous
rendez vous aurait pu rêver d'une
mauvaise d'une meilleure homo meilleur
départ pour cette candidature ce
cafouillage avec gabriella grand court
avec la machine les républicains
auraient pu démarrer autrement bon vous
savez ceux qui se sont passés maintenant
les choses sont régularisés donc j'en ai
parlé c'est un peu une tempête dans un
verre d'eau
la candidature était déjà actée gabriela
grands courts et moi nous avons jugé
plus opportun que ce soit moi qui soit
titulaire et je l'en remercie gabriel
qui m'a appelé en ce sens je ne serais
pas permis de lui proposer cela donc
c'est ainsi maintenant on est là pour
rassembler donc nous allons travailler
dans ce sens là prendrez-vous votre
carte auprès du mouvement des
républiques non je n'ai pas dit parce
que j'ai toujours été un peu
indépendante à ce niveau tout en étant
je revendique 1 est une femme droite une
femme de droite mais une femme droite
également mais je n'ai pas l'intention
de prendre ma carte des républicains je
travaille pour rassembler parce que vous
avez l'art du in et du off pas vraiment
vous savez parce que j'ai quand même
montré dans tous mes combats politiques
que je travaillais avec mes amis dans un
regroupement
par exemple bape et en chant c'est
vraiment ce n'est pas un mouvement
politique mais c'est quelque chose qui
nous rassemble avec des valeurs communes
et c'est sur ça que je veux aller alors
une campagne face essentiellement aux
sortants jean philippe unis lors ce sera
amical court 3 syed glacial alors moi je
ne vois pas cette campagne comme vous la
voyez monsieur walton je la vois je vais
pas une question juive je viens jouer
avec les quatre autres candidats
nous ne sommes pas que deux nous sommes
quatre pour l'instant son site mobile
mais en fait vous savez on a bien vu
dans toutes les statistiques qui se
seront passés depuis quelques années
quelques moments souvent le candidat le
moins attendu celui qui arrive donc moi
je ne néglige personne tout le monde a
droit à sa chance dans ce dans ce pas un
combat en tout cas dans cette course est
en fait moi je pense que cette campagne
devrait être correct cordiale est en
tout cas moi j'ai des balles dans deux
mois je ne sais pas moi je ne l'entends
fait attendu sur ses concurrents les
dirigeants de ma part de dire oui mais
palma par l ipaf risque est de ma part
moi je dis simplement que je ne
m'étendrai pas nous n'atteindrons pas la
lumière des autres en pour briller nous
allons briec notre propre ligne en ont
pas besoin d'éteindre les autres donc
nous allons travailler de manière très
cordiale il faut savoir être tueur
sylvia cet automne
jamais de campagne propre sur quelle
argumentation allez-vous batailler
contre jean thriller le sortant alors
vous savez je pense que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cette conception de la
politique et j'ai envie que ça change
parce que souvent malheureusement ça
arrête les gens de bonne volonté les
gens de bonne volonté qui ont envie de
dire bon on a envie de croire à quelque
chose allons-y ça va les arrêter
c'est vrai que ça peut être un peu ça
peut être un peu musclé on va dire de
l'analyse en détail par contre il y
aurait des projets qui m'intéresse
énormément et ces projets là je veux
vraiment les porter alors que le sortant
n'a pas su mener
je ne sais pas s'il a su mener mais moi
je vous aime ou non non j'ai dit
simplement que moi je m'engagerai dans
la protection de l'enfance dans
l'égalité hommes femmes dans l'économie
au niveau 2 des très petites et moyennes
entreprises au niveau de la santé des
personnes âgées de l'indivision
ces projets là ce sont des projets que
j'entends tous les jours que j'entends
tous les jours cela j'ai envie de les
porter mais alors comme lui au sein par
exemple utiliser territoriale de
martinique puisque vous travaillez
ensemble vous avez alors un contrat de
gestion sur des thèmes que vous abordez
hui le contrat de gestion ne veut pas
dire qu'on s'oublie au niveau de nos
différences on a travaillé ensemble et
il sait dire ça continue et ça va
continuer pendant cette cette mandature
mais ça n'empêche pas que nous avons
nous avons toujours dit d'ailleurs que
nous n'étions pas assujettis il est
normal que le jeu démocratique se place
en martinique dans le sud est en fait
vous savez la seule la seule réponse que
je peux vous donner c'est les urnes le
10 le 10 juin vous ne pourrez pas passer
sur l'étape le regard que vous portez
sur le mans la mandature de jean
philippe miller qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous non moi je vous dis que je
juge gens pensent je viens des choses
que je veux dire je mens j'entre je
pense en tout cas que je pourrais être
peut-être plus présent que lui à
l'assemblée nationale c'est quelque
chose qu'il met en capacité de porter et
je pense également que dans le groupe
dans le grand groupe des républicains et
de droite je pourrais porter des projets
qui seront peut-être mieux entendu que
ce qu'il aurait été plus présente pour
c'est déjà une accusation que vous
porterez dans sa fonction actuelle
parlementaire nous fait pas le job quoi
ce n'est pas une accusation c'est une ce
sont les fins il vous suffit d'aller sur
les gens cruels
il vous suffit d'aller sur le site de
l'assemblée nationale alors comment vous
et peut être davantage présente à paris
en étant plus présent toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont brigué le poste ont
promis aussi
oui je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
manières de fonctionner fait que quand
quand je m'engage essaie de tenir mes
engagements donc je pense que je serai
le faire vos amis de droite estiment que
donc la nuit place est plus connue et
dont le travail est saluée en tant que
conseillère est ce que par exemple la
gestion du lycée schoelcher de la
rentrée qui avait été annoncé comme
explosif dangereuse risquez vous avez su
désamorcer cette bombe est ce que c'est
votre principal fait d'armes qui fait
que vous pourrez mieux porter votre
parole auprès des habitants du sud
il est une il est évident que en fait
cette médiatisation à laquelle j'ai eu
droit à montrer que en tout cas j'étais
une femme déterminée et qu'ils étaient
capables de régler les choses parce
ramener aux ambitieuses façon pour être
pour être ambitieux soit être déterminée
donc
et donc c'était c'était un petit peu ce
que les habitants de gaza les habitants
de rien ça l'est connaissaient mon
engagement de la même façon que le sud
est peut-être que la martinique ne
mesurait pas et c'est vrai que depuis ce
dossier là que j'ai pas seulement j'ai
réussi à le régler avec le sud savent
aussi que vous avez par exemple tourner
le dos à andré lesueur
alors vous savez que c'est c'est aussi
ma manière de faire quand les choses ne
vont pas forcément je préfère en tout
cas me retirer plutôt que je devais
jouer dans le dos des gens et c'est pour
ça que vous ne prenez plus de kurt nulle
part oui c'est ça s'est un peu fait en
même temps ça me permet quelque part
d'être un peu libre et surtout
rassembleuse parce qu'il ya des gens qui
se reconnaissent dans ma manière de
faire la police comment ferait vos
campagnes silva 7 soutenons rappelle que
cette conseillère exécutive aussi vous
allez jouer sur cette marque là
également
puis laquelle vous fait celle de
conseillère exécutive je vais en train
en tout cas travailler sur mes capacités
personnelles de travail je suis je
reconnais que c'est une force de travail
je me retrouve dans l'action est donc là
dessus je pourrais effectivement parler
mais pas seulement je veux parler de
tout mon parcours de toute ma vie de
tous mes engagements aussi bien au
niveau associatif qu'au niveau politique
qu'au niveau personnel etc par exemple
je suis très engagé dans sos crise ce
sont des sujets qui m'intéressent et je
vais faire valoir sa parce que mon but
c'est quand même de gagner et de montrer
qui je suis
ce sont toutes ces participations dans
votre vie associative dans d'autres
mandats politiques qui font que vous
dites que finalement la députation c'est
là qu'on peut faire bouger les choses
alors et vous avez tout à fait raison je
pense que là on a vraiment des curseurs
qui peuvent permettre de trouver en bas
des solutions en martinique alors je
suis ambitieuse parti nick je sais que
ça ne va pas être facile je ne connais
pas l'assemblée nationale je n'y ai pas
mis les pieds alors s'engage aussi
intégrer certaines valeurs du secteur
mais vous savez ce qui compte aussi pour
moi c'est la transcription du relais
vous savez je suis très étonné de voir
que beaucoup de jeunes filles qui sont
excellentes à l'école qui sont très
bonnes en politique mais qu'on va
retrouver dans les missions
d'organisation de bureau mais qui ne
sont pas en première ligne mais moi j'ai
envie de leur montrer qu'on peut le
faire avec karine rousseau nous serons
d'ailleurs l'une des rares équipes où il
ya deux hommes deux femmes donc la
parité est respectée à notre niveau et
ça permettra peut-être aux valentins
oliana orlan au clos et de pouvoir se
dire que elles sont en capacité de le
faire
elle peut le faire parce que nous
traçons la voix est vraiment ça j'y
crois je crois qu'il faut vraiment mais
vraiment que tous et toutes celles qui
ont envie que les choses bougent en
martinique ne se contente pas en disant
apolitiques tassin macky sall pillay en
ou aller et plus on a des gens de
capacité et plus les choses avanceront
vous devrez contre également cette
argumentation selon laquelle plus honni
plus olé encore vous êtes déjà
consécutives vous avez des des fonctions
de la vie associative vous voulez
toujours plus toujours plus encore nick
s'est pas que j'en veux toujours plus
c'est que j'ai une énergie de vie qui me
permet de faire face à tout ça voilà et
donc j'ai envie de dire que on peut le
faire qu'en tant qu'on peut donner tant
qu'on peut faire on le fait et moi c'est
comme ça que je suis
demain je ne serai peut-être plus là
mais tant pis j'aurais fait ma part et
c'est fais ce que je veux faire
il ya le mot plaisir et miguel laventure
on est toujours aux atermoiements
concernant ces deux
ses deux collègues pour vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette attente ce
suspense insoutenable
je vous invite à les inviter
derrière ce micro bon en tout cas moi ce
que je peut se dire c'est que ce sourire
tout le monde gabriel et moi c'est acté
karine ces actes est maintenant le seul
peut-être que vous n'imaginez pas mais
ce n'est pas une décision forcément très
facile à prendre
il ya je vous ai dit alors il ya des
nombreux candidats à tous pourquoi ils
auront trois mois je souhaite qu'il le
soit je souhaite qu'ils le soient pour
que nous puissions vraiment démarré
ensemble tout ce travail tout ce travail
qui nous attend
parce que je pense que nous allons faire
cause commune que nous avons travaillé
ensemble sur un programme commun au
niveau en tout cas la martinique et
ensuite de le décliner dans le sud dans
le centre etc
je pense que nous avons une carte à
jouer vraiment vraiment et j'ai envie
que nous que nous arrivions tous et
toutes
le législatif ce sera en juin 2010 est
en mai des dites non s'il vers cet
automne est-ce que rivière salée 2020 ça
demeure toujours un objectif pour vous
alors vous savez moi je n'ose plus
maintenant me projeter parce que nous on
m'aurait dit que je travaillais avec eux
je serais avec monsieur marie gens que
je vous l'avais dit si j'avais dit que
ce n'est pas possible que n'arriva pas
finalement vers leur finalement les
réseaux sociaux mais également qu'ils
arrivent très bien j'avais dit que je ne
pourrais pas ça c'est fait donc vous
savez moi je ne présume pas vous laisser
seuls on veut voir les plus ambitieuses
qui calcule où j'ai en tout cas j'ai
c'est vrai que je ne calcule pas
forcément vous avez raison je ne calcule
pas je suis pas une femme calculatrice
sais pas si j'ai raison dans tout cas
gourmandise le suivant l'engagement que
c'est une ambitieuse aussi la section
bien vous avez ça me fait sourire parce
que ce qu'on dit ça parce que je dis
enfin enfin une femme a le droit d'être
ambitieux en politique il n'ya pas que
les hommes qui sont ambitions petit lait
ça me fait plaisir ça ouvre la voie je
suis contente de ceux de cette
conclusion merci d'avoir été ce matin
avec nothing has reached soutane on
rappelle que vous êtes candidate dans la
circonscription du sud pour le mois de
juin prochain demain nous aurons un de
vos adversaires ce sera david inhalent
au monde ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle bonne journée merci à vous